>>> TOMORROW PRESIDENT BIDEN
WILL HEAD BACK TO THE MIDTERM
BATTLEGRND STATE OF
PENNSYLVANIA FOR THE SECOND OF
THREE SPEECHES PLANNED THERE I
LESS THAN A WEEK.
IN A PRIMETIME ADDRESS FROM
PHILADELPHIA THE PRESIDENT WILL
OUTLINE WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE
DESCRIBES AS, QUOTE, THE
CONTINUED BATTLE FOR THE SOUL OF
THE NATION.
>> HE WAS IN WILKES-BARRY,
PENNSYLVANIA, YESTERDAY ONCE
AGAIN CALLING OUT SOME
REPUBLICANS FOR ABANDONING THEIR
COMMITMENT TO THE RULE OF LAW.
LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID.
>> YOU CAN'T BE PRO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND PRO
INSURRECTION.
YOU CAN'T BE A PARTY OF LAW AND
ORDER AND CALL THE PEOPLE WHO
ATTACKED THE POLICE ON JANUARY
6th PATRIOTS.
YOU CAN'T DO IT.
NOW IT'S SICKENING TO SEE THE
NEW ATTACKS ON THE FBI.
THREATENING THE LIFE OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS AND THEIR
FAMILIES FOR SIMPLY CARRYING OUT
THE LAW AND DOING THEIR JOB.
LOOK, I WANT TO SAY THIS AS
CLEAR AS I CAN, THERE'S NO PLACE
IN THIS COUNTRY, NO PLACE, FOR
ENDANGERING THE LIVES OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
NO PLACE.
>> LET'S BRING IN OUR CHIEF
NATIONAL AFFAIRS CORRESPONDENT
JEFF ZELENY.
JEFF, IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
THIS IS A STRIKINGLY DIFFERENT
TONE FROM THE PRESIDENT, YOU
KNOW, OBVIOUSLY IT COMES ON THE
HEELS OF A LOT OF LEGISLATIVE
WINS, YOU KNOW, I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FEELS LIKE THEY
HAVE THE WIND AT THEIR BACK IN
SOME RESPECTS BUT WHAT DOES IT
TELL US ABOUT WHAT HE'S GOING TO
SAY MAYBE TOMORROW NIGHT.
>> I THINK WHAT IT SAYS IS THEY
ARE TRYING TO MAKE THIS ELECTION
NOT ABOUT THEM.
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO TURN THE
FOCUS BACK TO REPUBLICANS AND
BACK TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WHO, OF COURSE, IS IN THE NEWS
EVERY SINGLE MINUTE IT ALMOST
SEEMS LIKE WITH THE COURT
FILINGS AND THE SEARCH AT
MAR-A-LAGO.
SO THE PRESIDENT AND THE WHITE
HOUSE THEY'VE NEVER REALLY
WANTED TO SPEND A LOT OF TIME
FOCUSING ON DONALD TRUMP.
YOU'VE SEEN PRESIDENT BIDEN FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING TRY TO MAKE
HIS PRESIDENCY ABOUT ANYTHING
ABOUT THAT, BUT THE REALITY IS
WE HAVE NEVER SEEN A FORMER
PRESIDENT SO OVERSHADOW AND
BLEED INTO A CURRENT PRESIDENCY.
SO THE WHITE HOUSE IS SIMPLY
LEANING INTO THAT AND TRYING TO
MAKE THIS A CHOICE BETWEEN
REPUBLICANS IN HIS VIEW MAGA
REPUBLICANS AND THE CURRENT
ADMINI